So three of these would reduce latency. The first one is correct.
That would reduce latency because every time you go through a hop,
well there's some time delay there. That you need the time for
the troops at the hop to see the message that came in and
then to start their fire to send the same message on to
the next hop. So if you have fewer hops its going to take
less time for the message to get across. You could reduce the
time it takes to go through each hop. So, if you can make
the soldiers at each node work faster, it would take
less time from the time that they see the message to
the time that they send it on, which is the time
when the next person will see it. So, the total time
to get across the network would also be reduced. The
third choice does not reduce latency. So adding colors would allow
you to send more messages, but it doesn't reduce the time
it takes for a message to get across. And we'll see
next that what adding colors would do would actually increase
the bandwidth of the network. But it doesn't improve the
latency at all. And finally, because Zeus can do things
that most people can't, other than possibly physicists in Switzerland.
If you could increase the speed of light, well that
would make the network faster. Not a very realistic option
and it wouldn't make it much faster because of the
transit time even with the regular speed of light, the time
it takes for the light to travel between
the points is infinitesimally small compared to the time
for all the other things like starting fires. But
all three of these would in theory reduce the
latency. The adding colors would not reduce the latency,
but it would increase the amount of information that
Zeus could send between those points in the same
amount of time. And that's what we call bandwidth.